[Music]
where are they hello
hello I'm back hello
yeah Hey Spanish boyfriend spend you can
sit up your butt must be hurting so much
wait are you in pain
you have an evening weeks my god oh let
it die what's up Bengt yo eat oh my god
yard again we're all back I'm back
yes Oh where's dinner bone gamers we're
back game ours yes it feels good to be
back isn't that right Oh lovely that's
me defeat the last episode we defeated
the Ender Dragon and boy oh boy
did that feel good
[Music]
Gaber keg now that I'm back things are
gonna become a lot more stricter no more
fun and games I got a family to provide
for now that's try to look how did you
get there
that's literally impossible all right I
want to start off just building just
easing into it building a little float I
want to build a boat I'm gonna build a
boat now
thank you I somehow lost the footage of
me building the boat we're just really
annoying I swear I built it no creative
mode no nothing I built that okay just
take my word for it just imagine like a
cool montage right now basically okay
I'm not gonna lie that looks pretty epic
I like it it's a Swedish Viking boat
technically this sail is something wrong
actually no it's on the right end it's
hundred percent correct and just how I
want it ah like if they're not it's cool
stop talking stop talking we work here
we don't speak embarrassing this is
embarrassing so I'm gonna be honest I
think technically no don't go through
spent you can't come with me to the
Endor
now I don't it's too dangerous we're not
doing it I don't even know if it's
possible for a dog to go today in there
you know I am sure it is possible but
it's a bad idea
stop Sven stop yeah I know I know you
missed me but I have to go to the Ender
on my own
so technically for me the series is over
it ended on episode 30 I want to keep it
intact that way you know in terms of
storytelling or whatever come back
please basically what I mean by that
it's just like things like there's a lot
of stuff in the game I can do but I also
didn't want it seem like I was stalling
defeat the Ender Dragon
when technically I could so I decided to
just do it so so basically to explain it
the series is over but the series
continues its like the OVA of enemy at
this point ok just see it as that we do
have a lot of stuff left that it's
obviously very integral to the game
which is finding an end city which is
what we're gonna do now all right gamers
I know I know I just got back I want to
find an end city which means we gotta go
back ok but actually before we go to the
Endor there's something I really really
want to try that I haven't done because
we're probably gonna travel through the
air now they're a lot more now and I
know the fastest way to travel the
nether span that changed my mind you
can't come with me let's go let's go
gamers lifespan come on
can I just I want ice basically but I
don't know can I mind this no why not
doesn't need to be pure ice what the
fact is that an end of my guy I
accidentally threw the ender pearl and I
spawned a creep 5% chance to spawn this
is a goal ender poo cool
all right I've been waiting to say this
for a long time
that's right we're gonna head off me and
my boy and find some ice just like old
times man just like old times look at
IKEA tower so go [ __ ] you know honeymoon
is epic and all but there's nothing like
going on a trip with your minecraft dog
now where was the ice I forgot nothing
like witnessing a sunrise with your boy
god damn I miss Mike the thing is like
clearly at this point it has peaked
summer's over the series technically it
reached his conclusion but I just want
to have fun with it so damn it I'm gonna
keep playing why is there a chicken here
excuse me water chicken which way to ice
how did you get here
no you cannot get in the bug curse water
chicken explain your presence you are
far away from what a sheep sent you
you know what our she and what was his
favorite color all of them Oh what does
she uh we're under attack shoosh very
well you can come with this I understand
you're scared oh god I'm scared too
let's go
I just wanted ice that's all I wanted
goddamn what is she must be angry sorry
you can't fit in the boat it's not my
fault I'm sorry there was ice over here
right there's a mushroom biome you know
I said this before and I'll say it again
the series ends when sweat dies
Oh God which is that bird there it is
the blue eggs does your name chicken
cheep-cheep-cheep that's a great name oh
yeah it's snowing now polar bear all
right stay here sheep sheep sheep that's
a great name for a chicken I got a see
nothing like hanging out with your dog
in your chicken I'm some ice stop
okay yeah it works excellent so this is
what we need
I'm just gonna keep farming this sorry
environmentalist the real reason why
they I suppose are melting Erin excuse
me
oh it's polar bear it's so cute hello
polar bear hey what's your problem polar
bear I'm innocent I'm innocent polar
bear oh he thinks I'm attacking Bevin
don't worry poor little bear I have no
quarrel with you look I mind a mite it's
meant protect me
can I put a leash on him hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah who's tough guy
now huh god damn water sheep angry yeah
yeah let's say get in the boat
yes I think you're super fast oh my god
oh my god well well it's out of control
ah spread cheep-cheep-cheep Sven look
away two seconds okay epic he
disappeared I had a baby okay I guess
you're coming with me to now new friend
where your mama go I'm your mama
what do you mean what kind of question
is that I'm your mama
oh I know I can call him pool um which
is like friend in Swedish laughing oh
he's crying hey hey I'm not raising some
coward all right stop crying eater
Salman there you go stop crying
oh my mom lift me did Bambi cry when his
mom died No
Oh God can the boat get in the boats
fine
get in the boat yes this is a weird
episode whoa dang
now when I go with Sven okay so then
you're ready to ride oh don't worry
hundred percent safety what are you
crying a plan huh Oh boohoo
I like how chicken has just decided to
stay there he's like it's too cold I
can't move hello are you okay are you
all right why are you not moving stop
crying
oh my god [ __ ] what do you want here I
gave you Salman you want gold I got gold
oh my gosh so ungrateful my god jump
jump 360 jump
what's up you're looking for your wife I
haven't seen her can't help you buddy
apparently there's Eagle oozing
minecraft too that's another thing I
haven't found yet what yeah I know it's
cold slang how do you think my meatballs
are doing
you're lucky to still have yours by the
way what's with my attitude
where is fun go there yes hahaha
they're so cute they really need to make
dogs swim faster my god insane no spend
read where the cheap cheap cheap gold
and the polar bears gone to I guess you
can come with me lame okay so I have the
packed ice it's time to head back gamers
damn he's fast for a polar pattern over
the Minecraft ocean yeah this is where
we float find the polar bear friend I
said [ __ ] get in the boat on its parent
tried to kill me it was a lot of drama
wish he would stop crying cuz now I am
his mom
[Music]
Hey look boat I must surely have gone
here before
what how'd I miss this oh my god
suspicious - Sven I found suspicious -
now for those of you don't know
suspicious - doesn't random thing and
it's just like real life if you find a
suspicious do always eat it Oh anything
suspicious-looking food-related always
eat it here we go and I have night
vision look at that pretty epic
suspicious - thank you and it's gone
those five seconds was epic so yeah
we're gonna capture every animal in the
game but we're also gonna capture every
enemy in the game
someone proved on the subreddit that you
can actually catch the ender dragon in a
boat and I'm like they did it in and
they did it in creative mode though but
that means it's possible where are we
what is this t-then nothing like taking
your polar bear for walk in the desert
only in Minecraft what is this why is
this here a pool on stop that hop on in
polar bear more like oh god no no stop
crying start Oh God
he's alive there it is there's our
beacon of trust I don't understand why
he's resisting I'm trying to save your
life stop resisting all right since
you're a polar bear I guess you can live
here okay time to build out our ice so I
think you place them like diagonally and
the boat will work on y'all this is
scary like I should probably run this
through a test yeah no that doesn't work
so does these not have to be there Oh
God Oh God but if that's how it's gonna
be yeah that is that is how it works
okay maybe I can be able to safety
underneath or something oh god that's
uncomfortable this is the worst idea
ever
I don't like bridges and it has nothing
to do with history I honestly don't see
how anyone can like them how is that
there what hey hey oh stop
stop aah
Oh might stuff all right I guess I'll
just do this now it just got to plays
all the eyes wish you feel sexy bet it
feels pretty good I like this now oh wow
I have a lot more ice than I thought nah
we're gonna go so fast that flash will
have to change his name to not so fast
yeah now I really don't have to keep
going but I'm going anyway I want to say
it how much speed we can build up here
we go
you ready for ultimate speed you think I
was fast when I used to potion of speed
or you ain't
I understand you don't know if this
would be here we go oh my god
that was awesome
oh god I feel dizzy
damn now that's fast I like that that's
awesome today we're actually exploring
something very exciting which is an end
City what their citizen in the end yes
ah okay here we go gamers oh my god this
is ridiculous
you guys enjoying your time here
you're free oh yeah you can get the I
forgot okay we'll get the egg later but
as you gamers can see there's something
over here
you thought the end was the end of
Minecraft well no there's a way to go
even further beyond would you guys free
creeper what here we go
oh man damn so if you go through here
and I think you have to throw an ender
pearl it's actually get in maybe there's
a way to use a piston to push you down
yeah wonder if that works actually I
just had a gamer pee you ever had one of
those to get the ender dragon egg so you
can hatch your own ender dragon
you got to push it with a piston and
then put a torch underneath I think that
was it I'm not entirely sure and I
should probably double-check here goes
nothing gamers okay it worked what
dragon egg that's so cool and I said
that in the most on a rhombic way
possible dragon egg that's so cool
but it's epic it's a fake alright be
quiet because my question was fairly
simple can you push yourself down so you
don't have to use an enderpearl to go
through the Ender dumb ideas come from
dumb people everyone never forget II
would I do yeah and then we put this
here and then we can just walk through
right Hey look at that I did science i
dad science what is this damn it's like
purple cactus whoa well I of course know
what this is because I'm minecraft
veteran this is space fruit can I eat it
whoa that is teleported whoa
so that's how you do it huh you've been
snacking all along and you haven't been
sharing so this is bedrock and for those
who you don't know that's what happens
when we no but your mom meets sorry
please slight smash like on video and
Bide merge big brain
and we can do the same thing to go back
baby
remote getaway cool you should probably
put a lever instead but you can't my
trick Bing bong Bing Bing bong okay
so excuse me have you seen your city
where you come from
we gotta find so let's just head in one
direction south there's n cities I know
there is we just gotta find them
hello I wish I could bring Garrigan here
what if you can make Jurgen fly that
would be epic
like a Pegasus listen Microsoft I'm
giving you these ideas for free you
understand this so I think NC is
actually quite rare you gotta be careful
in the end though cuz you fall down you
lose all your stuff which has never
happened to me of course but oh god oh
god do I not like this finger very
sweaty don't release your Shift key
whatever you do feelings oh my god I
just realizing it makes perfect sense
so the nether is Netherlands right and
the end is Swiss because there's cheese
everywhere so what we're looking for is
obviously an end city and in the end
city is where we'll find the alight tram
which makes it so you can fly in the
game how cool is that
I never use one before and I'm so
excited Felix when you come back to
married life what are you most excited
about a light rock I what is he saying I
don't know he's speaking language of
gods
I like try please now hello
I don't like bridges I've said this
before and I'll say it again I don't
like bridges don't like cheese that much
either to be honest so this is a double
whammy I like it melt I like cheese melt
that okay sorry relax it's like they
they created the the nether right which
is awful and then they decided hey let's
make something worse
in Chief's I assume n cities are as
radars in other cities but you keep
going in one direction you eventually
find 100 that's another end portal and
they're men more like n they're mad am i
right
I wonder what happens if I feed a chorus
fruit to bang will he teleport so this
is basically another way back home if we
get lost yes there it is finally I walk
for days I reek of cheese but I'm ready
damn is that a boat why their boat damn
that's huge dude oh god I'm about to
level up but ah then I won't be level 69
anymore oh yeah that is so cool hold on
let me get it footers that is sick
they're like why is this creeper here
and why does he look so sexy hey I don't
like bridges don't like them very much
because crossing bridges it's very tough
things can happen things can happen
Oh No Oh God made a lot of mistakes on
bridges in the past so therefore I try
to cross bridges very fast
oh god I ran out
I nailed it dumbass cheese cheese is so
dumb it's the dumbest thing okay here we
go
whoa yes those I I've been meaning to ah
nope stop stop it's conduits stop stop
shield haha oh yeah
he'll the city at the end of the game
hello oh my god it's a thing what I'm
flying
why am i flying oh they're making me
fart it all makes sense
oh stop I kind of low-key don't want to
fly though okay fine
I guess I'm flying so these stop I think
these are light sources and rod all the
rods alright I've seen what people use
those for ok gamers were in
all right let's go please they teleport
it they are actually farting seriously
mine cried Oh got him and you're up -
ulka she'll actually I'll accept your
farts shoot me
yeah ah yes but yeah yeah you made one
big miss a you made one that's right I'm
so close to not be level 69 that's so
sad alright we're gonna climb excuse me
go into the top gamers whoa whoa no no
no no no that up ah Oh God stand up
gaming the stand of gaming okay all
right and up and up and that stop
are they're shooting each other I'm done
now ah
no stop
whoa and inches in the end man ah stop
and their part I'm going in god damn
this race is a lot more dangerous than I
thought
are they teleport the snakes so I think
you can make something with a shulker
shell guess we'll have to do it later
this is not stop burning all right let's
see what's it Oh and entered diamonds Oh
efficiency for mending fortune what
that's awesome alright I'll put that in
there
how convenient I could put the dragon in
that's alright we go gamers that's
really good loot here has anyone made
the farting analogy joke yet cuz that's
hilarious
curse of binding garbage damn the other
chest was so good though that's like the
best chest I've ever gone yes are weird
I will top oh god we are Oh God put me
down put me down
Oh God okay so this is one of many
this is a really cool how do I get this
pickaxe fortune three mending efficiency
poor is there a better pickaxe
efficiency five I guess found another
chest Wow
hey I'll take it man watch your shot
yeah I don't understand how these people
got along before I came
put me down Oh God okay all right god
that's my life
[Music]
Oh
minecraft veteran everyone shows how
it's done
No
that's what I taught you taught Hey look
a little brewing stain hey instant
health I'll take it
there it is live one more
there it is nothing's gonna stop me from
getting my pants just kidding unbreaking
3 hey I'll take it so to get these you
flip and there it is gamers we have the
Elijah the sky's the limit gamers the
sky yes hahaha
what look at this dude
look at this dude I think notes taught
can I bring this home
oh my god and now we go back home baby
yeah we have the Elijah whoa I'm so cool
yeah
then can I wear the dragon oh my god
[Music]
don't worry spin it's just me yes
all right gamers thanks for watching
another episode of Minecraft next
episode we're gonna fly baby we're gonna
make some shelter boxes and it's gonna
be epic
check out the merch we have a hundred
million club merch out now limited time
only how else are you gonna rep the
channel come on check it out and see you
guys next time it's good to be back bye
bye